ladies and gentlemen welcome back
Kyle ash and Rhoda in the building how
you doing man very well how are you very
very well indeed I'm happy to have you
on it's been a long time coming first
and foremost for the listeners that
don't know who you are why why do you
think that I'm speaking to you today why
do you think I reached out man that's a
good that's a very good question last in
judgment no I actually you know I think
it's an interesting time I know you
found this article about asking
ourselves the question what do we want
to want you know has a lot to do with
with reevaluating our values and and our
desires and I think you know a lot of us
are being forced to do that throughout
the this disco vid situation so it's
kind of a good time to talk about talk
about that and see if we might be able
to do it in a more strategic or skillful
way I think you've answered my my
reasons pretty accurately there man yeah
I am I stumbled across your blog post
what do you want to want on your blog
and I was blown away man it's a 60
minute read or so and I absolutely
adored it and I was 10 minutes in and I
was already scouring around online
trying to find your email address and it
turned out that you already followed me
on Twitter which made everything in an
awful lot easier so yeah I have got you
on because I just want to go through
this blog post it's one of the most
fundamental concepts that I've never
heard spoken about before and I think
there's an awful lot of people listening
and no tone of audience members who will
really benefit from this so that's
that's why we're here we're going to go
through it so first
things first why is working out what you
want to want important so mostly because
you don't want to live a life that you
regret at the end of it right I think I
think that when we when we follow our
kind of default desires we're much more
likely to find ourselves a place in life
that we didn't really want to or mean to
get to so so I think I think that's you
know that's kind of the big one but but
that also there's there's a lot of
things along the way it's not like that
that can benefit from from asking
yourself this question so actually I
knew you're going to we were going to
talk about this so I kind of pulled some
of my favorite quotes from the article
that I think emphasize some of these
points better than then I could live off
the cuff yeah so so Ralph Waldo Emerson
in in self-reliance has this line my
life is for itself and not a spectacle
and I think our default desires so often
push us towards trying to create a life
that is a spectacle something that you
know looks great to others but itself
feels kind of maybe empty or off of you
know off-center from what what we would
truly want for ourselves and actually
that that it reminds me I mean your
audience may be more familiar now with
the idea of mimetic desire that's gotten
really popular since Peter Thiel's
started talking about it there's this
idea that that originated with the
sociologist Rene Girard that basically
means that we naturally want what those
around us want so those are kind of our
default desires and until in his book
bizerta when he talks about how kind of
realizing this helped him switch tracks
from
a legal career that he was you know
getting really far into and and had
incredible outlook and and switching
into tech which which made his life a
lot a lot better I mean you have better
outcomes and it was just more aligned
with his his true values I think if you
get so if we get stuck in these mimetic
or default desires they disconnect us
from our actual ones and I think there's
this there's a really beautiful it's a
two sentence quote from Proust from
Swans way that gets into I think the
nuance of why desiring you know our
defaults can be dangerous he says to
think that I've wasted years of my life
that I've longed to die that I've
experienced my greatest love for a woman
who didn't appeal to me who wasn't even
my type so so like he was chasing this
woman and he actually like longed to die
like he was willing to give everything
to her and then at the end of it he
realizes that she wasn't even his type
so I think that you know it's house it
you know these these default desires can
be super seductive and if we don't apply
some level of awareness you know they're
going to take you places you don't want
to be so this yeah then I'd add just a
couple a couple extra points so I think
you know I think that we we've
experienced a lot of kind of breakdowns
in societal in trust in society to the
point where I think there's a
significant portion of the population
who is afraid to desire you know
anything other than you know immediate
comfort or and I think that you know
reassessing desires and realizing they
don't need to be what what those around
us kind of think they should be can can
be a really healthy way of rekindling
healthy desires
and then also inevitably in the long run
we fall into our desires create our path
of least resistance and in the long run
I think that we all end up following our
path of least resistance
Robert Fritz talks about this really
beautifully in this book called the path
of least resistance but so I think I
think well if we can shape our desires
even a little bit it can create massive
massive changes in in our lives and and
it allows us to trust ourselves and you
know experience flow more often right
like if you can trust your desires to be
in your best interest then it can it can
it can make life a little easier in some
ways man I really agree I think it's
such a fundamental question and that's
why I found it so fascinating when I
began reading the article and for the
people that I think you know this
article sounds great it will be linked
in the show notes below of course but to
everyone that's listening ask yourself
what do you want to want like genuinely
what do you want to want not what do you
want like I want that piece of cake I
want this car I want whatever it might
be like what do you want to want the
ability to program our desires to choose
our own path is something which has
never been gifted to us in as high
velocity as it has done right now right
you know we have the depth and breadth
of freedom that no other society in
history has had the first-ever Society
whose problems are problems of surplus
not problems of scarcity and with that
in mind it means that you get to do
things that you usually wouldn't be able
to but because of this mimetic
predisposition that we have where we
reflect the people who are around us and
their desires and this path of least
resistance which you mentioned which is
kind of a number of different things
like a genetic predisposition towards
certain bits and pieces and then you
compound
that this is the real pernicious thing
about it that you compound that over
time and that becomes patterns of
behavior which are increasingly more and
more difficult to change so your desires
that you have now which as we've
identified very well may not be chosen
that just kind of emergent from you
never actually looking at what you want
to want over time will become
increasingly harder to step out of that
value of right because like a river it
cuts a path that's ever deeper and then
after time you like well this rivers now
like Niagara Falls and it's going to
take a extra human superhuman effort in
order for me to redirect this flow of
water so yeah I think man it's um it's a
really fascinating really fascinating
thing to think and you were you
mentioned there about the the the quote
where this guy had realized at the end
of his life that it was a woman who
wasn't even his type I was talking to
Greg McEwan guy that wrote essentialism
and he said he was working with some
huge tech execs from Silicon Valley and
this guy who'd made it to the top of the
corporate ladder was very successful
basically said that his relationship
with his son was breaking down as his
teenage son who he essentially can't
speak to they can't have a conversation
his son wants to leave the room and
every enters a there is a terrible
terrible relationship you know and that
is someone Greg said who won at the
wrong game and holy [ __ ] if that's not
the sort of thing that makes the hairs
on the back of your neck stand up you
know this guy who's dedicated his life
towards something that he thought would
give him purpose and meaning and a sense
of fulfillment and is actually you know
in every by everyone's definition has
dedicated himself to a thing
but dedicated himself to the wrong thing
with time that he can never get back
live man that's hell
you know that's Hell incarnate on earth
yes pretty terrifying it's absolutely
terrifying okay so we understand that
working out what we want to want is
important because it allows us to
program our desires which in an essence
in programs are life a forms a
foundation upon which our behaviors can
draw from and also I like the idea of it
being kind of like an a trustworthy
friend you know or a good advisor on
your shoulder that if you have designed
desires you know that what you want to
want is a what you want is a good
indication of what you should want
because it's designed as opposed to
emergent next up what should we want
we've decided that we should want design
our once
what should we want got an entire world
out there to choose from one thing I
want to bring up this is just great
before we before I answer that I don't
want to make this sound easy or
something you know like the article is
written a few years ago and I you know
it's this isn't I'm not here pretending
to have mastered my every desire right
so so I'm very much like this is very
much a work in progress and do as I say
not as I do yeah well I think in this
great line that the Confucius had and QS
so Confucianism was like basically all
about reprogramming your desires so that
you could you would behave properly and
you know basically what we're talking
about here your your desires would line
up properly with what you want to want
or you know what you mean wanted what
Confucianism was pointing at and he
talked about how he measured his
progress over decades you know not years
or months or anything so I do think like
simple things just even stopping and
asking yourself this question could have
huge
huge dividends but but we're talking
about like fundamental programming and
there's definitely ways to support
change but but none of them are easier
painless I also want to say so I do
think that there are things that we can
all agree on you know we should you know
we should want that we would love to
want rather than you know the opposite
but but I think above all self-reliance
matters so the core thing here that that
that I think is is the most helpful is
the question itself and like you said
you actually you know kind of invited
the audience to consider the question
and I always love this as Indian sage
Krishnamurti like every time he would
give this talk he would he would kind of
force the audience into engagement with
the ideas don't take the ideas and like
organize it file it away you know your
Evernote like this is something to
engage with now in real time in reality
so so that being said you know
self-reliance matters there's a lot of
you know you a lot of this gets into
kind of moral territory and I am NOT
suggesting that I or anyone has kind of
moral superiority over you know over
ever you know what you think or is
trying to tell you what you should want
the suggestion is that if you do
dedicate yourself to some degree to
considering what you want to want and
shaping those there will be benefits but
so anyway but with that all being said I
think that there is some that most of us
can agree on so you know ultimately the
idea of wanting what is to some degree
seems pretty desirable that's
essentially achieving you know Nicci's a
more fatigue but then if we want to get
you know more specifically it seems that
your life life would be better if we
were to
the things that were nourishing for us
in the in the long run navall the
founder of angellist actually the other
day on Twitter had a really good tweet
he said and you know he is he's good at
tweets the he said the modern devil is
cheap dopamine so I think that's like
really great heuristic for what we don't
want to want right you know we we
ideally we are not designing ourselves
to desire cheap dopamine hits above all
cheap dopamine hits being like you know
candy or the intellectual equivalent you
know like a bad a badly constructed
Twitter feed or reddit or things like
that it goes it goes to everything as
well right it goes to that reply from a
random girl you've never met on
Instagram DM when you've got a
girlfriend to bolster your sense of
whatever like it goes to texting in the
car while you drive they got you know
there's so many iterations of that yeah
yeah and so I'd like to and I also I'd
like to imagine a spectrum of desires
you know so it's really helpful for me
to you know envision like the
enlightened sage on one side and you
know who who in you know for our
purposes whose desires lead to
eudaimonia and you know human human
flourishing and then on the other side
we have a caveman or if something that's
completely driven by their by their ed
by their lowest desires and this isn't
perfect right there's there's there's
you know there could be you know there's
like the noble savage idea and stuff
that I think we can talk about a little
bit more later but I think that that
spectrum helps you like if what side of
the spectrum does this desire land on
and I think that's a helpful way to
orient our desires I agree I think that
learning what you shouldn't want to want
first is a very easy way to to work this
out so people
who listened to episode 69 the most ever
played on mental models with George
McGill will know the power of inversion
it's really hard sometimes to work out
what makes us happy but it's quite easy
to explain how you would make a happy
person depressed and then if you flip
that on its head and you say well okay
if that's how I make a happy person
depressed if I either choose to do the
opposite of them I don't do the things
that would cause it or I do do the
things that would stop it like that's
how I make myself happier I need to wake
up on time and get sunlight and exercise
and see friends and drink water and have
healthy food and blah blah blah blah and
it's the same for this right what would
be when it comes to once ask yourself
and this is a this is a full deep throat
red pilling that me and Kylie giving you
throughout today this is an active
podcast this is not a passive one as
Kyle's already said but ask yourself
like what are the things that you really
should not want to want should you not
want to want the appreciation of people
who you don't care about that are not in
your immediate circle should you not
want to want a whole host of very
shallow very meaningless friendships and
all relationships and or sexual
encounters with people should you not
want you know continue to iterate on
that as much as you want but ask
yourself you know what would make what
once if you took them to their ends
degree would guarantee that you led an
unfulfilled life because I am man I can
make a list that's longer than my arm of
those things so I think that's that's a
pretty good place to start but you
actually um you created a like for areas
that you moved through in the blog post
right there was four different sections
why did you why did you choose those
four I think they were they were pretty
fundamental pretty um I don't want to
say not controversial but I think
they're they're pretty well founded and
and I actually you know a lot of them
came from inversions
so taking desires I had that I felt were
unhelpful and figuring out
looking as looking at them as closely as
I could right and and figuring out where
you know how could they be helpful
were they pushing me in a healthy
direction or not and if not how could I
change them and so so yeah we looked at
you want from from you know switching
from wanting Fame to to actually doing
something making change from wanting
extreme wealth to wanting frugal heart
from wanting to be extraordinary to
wanting the ordinary and from wanting an
easy life to actually desiring struggle
I thought man it's it that little sort
of paradigm thing that you've created I
really like and it is high-level wanting
an easy life wanting to be somebody
wanting extreme wealth and wanting to be
extraordinary those are four very very
common wants that people want but
probably don't want to want certainly
not when they actually fully appreciate
what the implications are of wanting
that want would you agree
yes I would I would agree fully good
good well it's just as well because I've
taken that learning from your blog post
mate so also yeah I am I'm banning you
from doing any more caveats throughout
the rest of this of this podcast man
like your article your article is is
fantastic and it is extensive not
exhaustive and if anyone's got a problem
with the fact that you don't go to the
nth degree or the end of the earth to
explain all of the different
possibilities then they can my DMS are
open they can come speak to me you're
just unloading wisdom today man and
everyone else can [ __ ] off so let's get
into it wanting an easy life versus
wanting a life of struggle
why would someone not want an easy life
why should they want a life of struggle
that son [ __ ] yes so first of all can
kill you
so so yeah there's Sheldon in a study of
his employees that retired at 55 versus
those at 65 and the people that retired
at 55 died significantly sooner than
those that were tired of 65 and that's
been you know there's tons of studies
they'll show you that if you retire
early
right and you live a normal retired life
you will die earlier there's also so
like struggle is universal there's
nothing we can do to eliminate it so if
we're able to embrace it again to like
whatever degree is possible for you now
it makes life you know you're fighting
against life a little bit less
paradoxically right Kelly McGonigal
actually has she has a ton of great
examples in her book the upside of
stress but my favorite is is this bit
where she talks about how our bodies
actually release different chemicals
depending on how we perceive a stressor
so if we think that a particular
stressful situation is just bad and
regret having to take it on and kind of
try to avoid it our bodies will put out
less helpful healthy chemicals so it's
basically they pump out this chemical
mix that's more cortisone heavy or sorry
cortisol heavy then then if we embrace
the stress as something healthy and that
can provide energy to get past obstacles
so if we allow ourselves to embrace a
stressor we will our bodies will
actually respond different physically
and release different chemicals into our
system that will that will give us you
know healthier better energy month
that's so [ __ ] cool and to link that
back you may have heard some Harris talk
about this
he uses his hilarious analogy where he
says imagine that spontaneously you just
were given the full physiological
sensations that you have at the end of
completing an incredibly hard
high-intensity workout
like you're just driving down the street
and that happens heart rates jacked up
through the roof you sweating like
you're panting you're tired you can't
breathe all this stuff you would be
terrified
you think holy [ __ ] [ __ ] what is
going on am I gonna die
darling darling ring the ring the
ambulance immediately
but reframe that reframe that at the end
of a workout that is the signal you're
chasing that is the discomfort you're
leaning into because it is a marker that
you have done something so that
immediately shows people for millennia
have been avoiding cold it's been a
thing that has killed countless
countless humans and now all of my
friends do cold exposure first thing in
the morning they're going get a cold
shower because they see that as a signal
that is something so that shows exactly
not only is there a mental reframing
which changes the way that we see that
discomfort or that struggle there's also
as you've identified there the reframing
then is reflected physiologically with
how our body responds to it - that's
super that's super cool yeah I mean the
examples go on and on you know
two-thirds of trauma survivors that have
actually experienced post-traumatic
growth and the difference between the
ones that experienced growth versus not
is as purely mindset and again you know
it's just some degree it's you know
there is a breaking point and you know
Nietzsche's idea that you know what
doesn't kill us makes us stronger is
obviously not 100% correct he lost his
mind and and and physically weakened and
never you know he reached a breaking
breaking point just like everybody can
but the the amount of pain that we can
take is is often surprising to us so
again an adults who late in life
actually experienced more struggles
throughout their life reported greater
satisfaction with their lives and a
stronger sense of purpose and made
more original contributions than those
who reported having a more consistently
pleasant life and you know there's you
know Viktor Frankl the author of man's
search for meaning actually considers
suffering suffering well to be one of
only three sources of meaning in life
the others being doing work you consider
significant and caring for another
person so you the case for struggle is
is significant sighs pretty seems pretty
bloody robust man here's one his his a
red pill moment for all of the type-a
go-getters out there - actually I don't
know whether you've heard these he
probably will have done but I'm being
given to you anyway Kyle first one
anybody that's ever owned a business or
has ever been to uni or done any group
work or worked on a project that they
care about think about what your
favorite part you're some of your
favorite memories that you have when
you're talking to other people about
that project the favorite memory is
never like when it was easygoing when
everything was sweet when you got to
rock up to work late and everything was
still moving fine the best memories the
ones that you recall are the 3 a.m.
finishes where you had two ordered
Domino's direct to the office and you
slept under your desk and you grinded
and grafted but you got it you got it
done you got that proposal finished and
then you got it you did the thing or you
you worked your art and your paint in
the shop and then you finally its launch
day and you finally just got there by
the skin of your teeth that is what you
remember that is the the the love that
you have for your project those are the
best memories that you have that's a
from Ben Bergeron's chasing excellence
podcasts are really really eye-opening
insight and ii think the other side of
that if you're a type-a personality who
really really wants to struggle
especially if you're a business owner
tomorrow don't touch your phone don't
look at a screen and don't do anything
don't read don't meditate on exercise
spend the whole day doing sweet [ __ ] all
and that will be that will be the
definition of a day of struggle because
you're just gonna be itching to go and
do [ __ ] but yeah both both of both of
those things kind of
a map on that easy life versus wanting a
life of struggles somewhere yeah it's
beautiful
and I do I want to say you know you said
no caveat this is not really a caveat
okay but I just I you know people can
take this the wrong way right so this is
in no way trying to promote self
flagellation
or fetishize suffering or belittling
suffering that is you know super intense
and and unhelpful so it's more of a call
to flinch less when something bad
happens and to let ourselves try things
where that are pretty much guaranteed to
add obstacles into our life that would
that's going to make it more of a
struggle but also very likely more
meaningful so it's not about adding
drama or you know any unnecessary drama
it's it's about how you act in the face
of struggle that already exists and
enabling yourself to choose harder paths
in life that will ultimately be more
fulfilling but will also necessitate
more struggle yes I like that I like
that a lot okay so wanting an easy life
people think I just want to coast along
but they're gonna die sooner they're not
going to find as much meaning they're
also going to have worse memories Viktor
Frankl a fictive uncle said it then it
is it's correct you know so that's line
dronin to that people should want a life
of struggle or at the very least lean
into the struggles that they have and
embrace them and see them as challenges
to overcome rather than kind of curses
to bear I suppose up next wanting to be
somebody versus wanting to do something
how does this map
so yeah this is this one is tough right
now rights because everybody wants more
attention right I mean and and and it
gets murky right because attention has
become valuable right like you can build
business off businesses off of the
amount of attention you get right so so
this one gets the nuance here is very
important but famous is you know
absolutely addicting it's one of the
most addictive things Adam Smith said
that to those who have been accustomed
to the possession or even the hope of
public admiration all other pleasures
sicken and decay which you can kind of
see like you know if you the pain of a
waning celebrity is you know this rule
and you can see it in their decisions
that they make right they'll make kind
of don't they'll agree too and sometimes
it's about money but a lot of it is
often about getting squeezing out the
last little bit of attention that they
can out of a career when they go on like
these humiliating game shows and stuff
like that so and another huge huge
danger with fame is that it puts our
happiness on the whims of those to whom
we're famous so the person who seeks
fame is is making their happiness
largely dependent on the opinions of
other people right so those those people
who have the power to build you up have
the same power to to tear you down and
you know I mean we see this all the time
kind of scapegoating right like
everybody will just pick pick a
celebrity who did some kind of minor
made some kind of minor infraction and
just tear them tear them apart Kevin
Kelly Kevin Kelly wrote a great article
just on advice and he pointed out that
anybody who's read a famous person's
biography should understand that you
don't want to be famous
you know it becomes super obvious that
that a life that makes a really great
story is not necessarily then the lies
the life that feels best to live while
you're in it so and again you know
there's there's there's obvious value to
fame you know a few things matter more
than your reputation but the point is
here that we should you know shift the
order so if you desire impact more than
attention then anything you achieve will
be based on a solid foundation and your
happiness won't disappear when the
attention does so so you know if
somebody makes an individual
breakthrough contribution
technologically or something they'll
become famous for 15 seconds but in most
cases when that fade fames as it
inevitably will because they're not the
type of people who are doing the work to
increase their fame or maintain their
fame daily right their happiness doesn't
go away because the work that actually
is meaningful to them which is creating
change creating in this case whatever
technologies still is there for them
right and so you know they might feel a
little twinge but it's nothing like you
know that the pain that a celebrity
feels when when the spike of the
spotlight is hey it's Fame for famous
sake isn't it and man the I actually
think I actually think that in all of
the article in all of your blog post the
wanting to be somebody is probably the
biggest red pill to swallow in there
it's certainly one of them and I don't
know how much you know about my
background but I was on a couple of
reality TV shows in the UK so like
that's the weather blue take wanker and
all that sort of comes from and no no
please for the love of Christ no no Kyle
stuff but what what happened I was on a
dating show love island which is
essentially if you can imagine what
eight weeks of television that looks
like what life would be like if
Instagram put a filter over it all
that's kind of how it comes across right
and what that does is people don't get
to win that show or be successful on
that show because of something that they
do or even something that they are it
just completely dilutes everyone down to
the lowest common denominator the people
that win might be very talented at a
thing but they don't win because of
their talent they win because of the
fact that they chose the right girl or
guy and have abs and got a tan and said
the right thing at the right moment like
there was a real talented boxer on there
there's been doctors on there's been all
sorts of people they didn't do well or
badly because of anything that they
actually did or created or had impact or
worked they were just there and gifted
Fame for no reason and the challenge
with that is as you've hit the nail on
the head like those who giveth can
taketh away and if you put your sense of
identity in your sense of happiness
around that Fame and that Fame is simply
hollow when it goes you're left with
nothing
whereas if you have it on a foundation a
very firm foundation of it being built
on something that you love to do that
you create that scales over time that
becomes anti fragile you know that I'm
sure there'll be times inventors if
there's anyone who's listening who's
ever got famous and then how'd it go
away
especially if you're an inventor you
might be actually like right thank [ __ ]
all of those that tensions gone I can
now actually get back to doing some work
right yeah if it's alright I have a
couple a couple questions
hit me one do you think that the cast
and I don't know if you you you've
you've kept in touch but but did life
get easier or I should say better or
worse for for for the majority of people
after the show and and to
manure your was was was the show and
kind of recognizing the danger of that
fame or that that taste of attention
that you you received did that was that
an impetus to you know start the podcast
and explore some of these other ideas go
yeah to really good questions one so
with regards to the other people on the
show like I still follow some of them
online I don't follow any of the girls
like I didn't speak to the girls while I
was on there so it's pointless to me
what following them when I'm off but
they you know some of the boys are doing
good a couple of them are on or the
reality TV shows or doing whatever
there's certainly a little bit of a case
of some of the guys who've got a taste
of Fame and are now sort of clinging on
to it some of the guys have now embraced
normality again and just see it as what
it was which was a good experience the
problem is that people want Fame for the
purpose of being famous they ought to be
famous for being well-known not famous
for having done something and it's it's
so dangerous man like a log on to hear
people talking on live streams about
their reputation or what people are
saying about them which was created off
the back of nothing like it was picked
up out at the back of no virtue no no it
just nothing nothing happened they were
selected the same way as a lightning
select a victim you know like just with
your hiney
a tiny little bit more discrimination
and um I don't know I think I think that
all of the guys certainly from my season
I think that they will they're slowly on
the path to kind of integrating those
two different worlds like the post sort
of Fame world or the the poster her
relevancy world and the the world where
they they still were and then on the
second one about kind of my insight into
that yeah
it certainly identified in me that I was
playing a little bit of a persona that
that root wasn't really the one that I
wanted don't get me wrong man if I was
able to get the sort of traction that
the top-level people because the show's
kind of got exponentially bigger since I
was on it five years ago if I was able
to get that sort of traction because of
this podcast or because of other stuff
that I do maybe some right here maybe
some whatever it might be if I was able
to get that kind of traction from
something that I genuinely care about I
would love it but even if I didn't I
don't care I do this podcast I don't
like I love the audience everyone that's
listening I love you bits and thank you
so much for being a part of this journey
because it is the the most fun most
engaging most exhilarating activity and
project I've ever worked on but in the
nicest way possible if you all [ __ ]
off tomorrow I'd still do it like I
would still be here still speaking to
people still still loving this process
and that's the most robust situation I
think to be in and you know I hope
everyone that's listening finds a thing
in their life and that could be being a
mother being a brother you know being a
good friend
being a good community so that could be
being a high-performing athlete or a
good businessman or someone who's
creative whatever it might be like if
you find that thing that makes you lose
yourself in it the Fame notoriety
wanting to be somebody can come and go
but the joy of the activity itself
remains and that's really pure a man
yeah especially I think like you pointed
to in creative creative work where you
know oftentimes the thing that you think
is best is maybe least appreciated and
so you have to and you know the thing
that gets you know most popular might
make you feel misunderstood or something
you know like yeah almost betrayed by a
fanbase so it's like and obviously for a
long time you have very little chance
monetizing
creative activities so few finds of the
yet that you would do either way and
that you know if you doing something for
attention is incredibly fragile endeavor
yeah I think that gets it's been
magnified right by social media because
the content often which is actually the
best or adds the most value or hits
people the deepest is also some sort of
the worst performing [ __ ] that goes out
on there you know like I can put I can
put a trailer out for an episode which
is taken two hours to research two hours
to record another couple of hours of
editing and then put a 60 second
subtitle trailer together upon on
Instagram or something in it kind of
just okay some people supported some
people don't but then you put up a
topless photo with a couple of emojis
and it absolutely flies well like you
gotta you gotta play the game and I you
know it is what it is you can't hate
that but it's so seductive right because
you think well I'm I just keep on
chasing what people the be somebody root
right why should I bother doing
something when I'm not getting the
volume of attention that I do when I
want to be somebody yes and I think I
think this is you pointed to the order
mattering right like the the thing that
you care deeply about is what's
important and then you're doing these
other activities that are essentially
marketing to you know to to sustain and
button play the [ __ ] game Kyle go to
play [ __ ] games mention yeah I'm a
marketer right like I like getting
attention is a good game right
but desiring fame for yourself for its
own sake is incredibly dangerous and
leads to very very bad places remember
what you said at the very start it was
about programming it right
news about the intentionality of what
you are doing like are you wanting the
attention or the the likes on your photo
because you genuinely think that that's
going to bring you happiness or are you
playing the game because you know that
if you do that it furthers something
which you truly care about that's the
difference between matrix and red pill
Amen okay so we should want to do
something not to be somebody it's going
to make us more robust if and when
there's somebody that we have become
goes away it also means that we don't
have our sense of self-worth linchpins
to other people's opinions of us and
that's so important as well like before
we move on [ __ ] man like being in
control of your own happiness or not
giving other people that control like
that's one of the principal reasons that
young people's relationships fail
because they're so terrified of opening
up to another person another human being
that they're going to be like they don't
they don't ever actually end up being
fully faithful to them because they're
terrified of what that means are they
they don't ever end up actually fully
opening up to them you know like it's
it's so important I think to not have
your sense of self-worth leveraged up
against other people's opinions for you
so we've got we want a life of struggle
we want to do something not to be
somebody next wanting extreme wealth
versus wanting a frugal heart what does
that mean so I think Arthur Schopenhauer
has this line that that I think frames
this whole point really perfectly he
says money is human happiness in the
abstract he then who is no longer
capable of enjoying happiness in the
concrete devotes his heart entirely to
money so like we just talked about right
if you are you know trying to go after
Fame for famous sake
that's almost like it's an abstract
version of love versus doing something
where you actually have to pour love
into something right so so in this case
it is you know when we have no other
more meaningful or purposeful or yeah
connection in our life money is kind of
the default that we assume will fill
that hole and so another way to look at
this is actually another Peter teal
example from Syria one he he he talked
about definite optimists verse
indefinite optimists and definite
optimists are optimists about something
in particular so entrepreneurs tend to
fit in this category so optimistic about
you know sustainable energy or you know
and what exactly that should look like
what specific piece needs to improve in
order to make the world better and then
indefinite optimists tend to they think
the world is going to get better but
really they they don't care how and and
these people tend to be in finance and
are obsessed with optionality because
really I think really because they lack
vision right and so if if money is the
most interesting thing that you think
you can collect you know like and you
don't have more concrete reasons for
achieving that right in some level about
finalities is incredibly freeing and
useful right but if if you just keep
going on and on and on and playing the
same game it's just you you haven't been
very imaginative right so so yeah so so
like like Fame wealth is super addicting
and it's easy to think the happiness
lies behind the next financial milestone
obviously if any of us who have been
lucky enough to make some money know
that that's that's truth
and then you know
an obsession with extreme wealth also is
is dangerous to your morals I think we
need some level of humility to admit
that but but so on our way to acquiring
wealth we may give ourselves more slack
and the actions that we take to acquire
it and then once we're wealthy it's
super easy to listen to the sick fans
around us that that hold us to less
strict moral standards than they do to
their peers so we began to feel that you
know more rules may not apply to us in
the same way so so I think the reframe
here that that I find really helpful
actually comes from Tim O'Reilly of
O'Reilly Media
they produce he's been in the tech world
forever produces a ton of like how-to
guides for programmers and things like
that but he link he he has this metaphor
that we we should think of of money as
gasoline on a road trip so it absolutely
sucks to run out of it so you have to
pay attention to it you have to make
sure that your tank is you know
reasonably full but the trip is not
about getting gas at all right so that's
not the purpose the purpose the gas has
a purpose to power your trip but the
trip is in no way if you would never
plan a trip around going to the gas
station right unless you were preparing
for a longer voyage so yeah another
another antidote is to to stoke our
desire to develop the frugal heart so
that's the switch right so obsessed from
obsessing to extreme wealth right and
that's where I kind of used the word
extreme right because obviously wealth
provides so many powerful options and
and enables so many important things in
life that it obviously matters but from
that kind of moving from the obsession
to extreme wealth to developing a frugal
heart and I stole that from this novel
Zorba the Greek is it's basically the
ability to enjoy the little things in
life
so like anyone who goes you know who
likes hiking knows that that life
doesn't get better than a really good
hike with you know someone you love and
those cost very very little so so if
were able to enjoy more things about our
life as it is
I think we're less likely to go into
debt for things that we really don't
care that much about or add unnecessary
stress to keep us up with the you know a
pup with the consumption of those around
us and I think you know a frugal heart
also creates freedom by just lowering
our personal burn rate no so if you can
you can get through life without you
know the most expensive cars or you know
your brand new clothes every month or
whatever you know whatever it is for you
if you can lower your burn rate it
creates freedom and possibility and
choices that go away once you have a
certain you know I mean you have to
maintain a certain lifestyle
I'm HUD's Morgan Housel writer on
collaborative fund and ex Motley Fool
writer as well on here one of the best
Twitter accounts for finance and wealth
management stuff and he said he has this
amazing definition of wealth he says
wealth is the Ferrari that you didn't
buy it's the square footage in the house
that you didn't purchase
wealth allows you to do what you want
with who you want when you want for as
long as you want with no one telling you
to do anything else you know that there
you go that is what it is it's an
allowance of freedom but the frugal
heart thing the wanting to do something
and the wanting to embrace the ordinary
those three go together for me I think
the wanting an easy life versus wanting
a life of struggle actually sits outside
of it but this is something that people
that are listening might have realized
for noticin themselves during lockdown I
know that I certainly have like I've
never paid such close attention or taken
such joy from tiny little things
do a morning walk every morning and I
know the order in which the trees on the
street that I walk down on my morning
walk I know the order in which they left
I know this one went first and our that
one went about two days later and this
one's got a little bit of flower blossom
on it and this one's got that and like I
know the shape of them I know the color
of them I know and it sound it's like
I've turned into some horticultural
fanatic or something like that which I
haven't but the point is that because
the amount of novelty that was going on
in my life got downregulated because
there's so much less stuff that I can do
because the pandemics brought that down
I'm now paying closer attention to
things that were right under my nose the
whole time and I'm now actually taking
joy from them despite the fact that they
haven't changed like my Gardens been the
same garden as it's been for five years
but I never actually watched the some of
the plants and the flowers in my garden
bloom and it will and then leaf and then
do all these other bits and pieces but
I'm taking joy from that you know and
it's like that there's definitely an
amount of frugality that's occurred due
to the increase or the reduction in
novelty I think that the the pandemics
caused yes I love your leaf example I
there others there is nothing I actually
I caught myself one day staring at a
single leaf on the ground for like 15
minutes and it's amazing that these
things that we you know normally will
just walk by like you said if you attend
to them if I just place your attention
on them and you keep it there they cease
to be boring and they become like
impossibly interesting and beautiful
right like these any little mundane
thing especially biological you know the
organisms like like a leaf like and yeah
I think that that is that's that is like
the perfect example for developing fruit
hey I've been thinking I've been reading
your blog post a lot I put it on my
oh here's one for the people who
listened to the most recent ifox episode
it's a long blogpost I didn't want to
read it on my laptop I used the center
Kindle Chrome extension to send it on to
my paperwhite and it was delivered with
all of the formatting retained I was
able to edit the font size sent to
Kindle on Google Chrome extension store
go and get it it's free and it will turn
your e-reader into an article reader at
the the literally they click of one
button and it keeps the audio the
author's name and as tightly it's
absolutely phenomenal
final thing on the frugal heart before
we move on another Morgan Housel ism
from when I spoke to him I was talking
about the fact that I feel like there's
a genetic set point
it's obviously socialized but it comes
so early in life I don't think that you
can really class it as that or you can
class it less as that sure say you have
a spending set point a materialist set
point mostly that you've probably
inherited from your family your siblings
your parents if your parents were very
keeping up with the Joneses II they were
always buying a new car if people were
spending a lot of money on birthday
presents and Christmas presents and the
relationships were always shows of of
gifts and showering each other in this
sort of thing you will have grown up
with that and if you are unable to
deprogram that desire you'd better hope
that you get a good performing job that
pays a lot of money because if you don't
you're gonna spend your entire life
chasing more and more in an attempt to
try and fulfill that materialist desire
whereas the frugal heart side of this
the person who's just happy looking at a
leaf and that's another - like a stupid
extreme example but the person who would
be happy spending an afternoon with the
person that they love going for a
beautiful walk and having a nice meal on
the evening time as opposed to it being
some five-star hotel trip away to the
Seychelles with a fresh fruit float in
basket and fireworks and all this sort
of stuff you know the difference between
those two in terms of enjoyment is the
same but as you identified the
leveraging of the system into
of how much they need to work to achieve
the same level of happiness because
presuming that your the money that you
earn is a function of how much you have
to work it's totally different so yeah
man frugal ha I'm I'm all over it yeah
thank you point to the point isn't to
you know make less and go join a commune
or something it's the point is to
liberate yourself from the unending need
for more so it's not about you know
doing less it is it is about enjoying
more okay so final section wanting to be
extraordinary versus wanting to embrace
the ordinary we kind of already touched
on it with the with the leaf thing right
yeah I love how you you tied those three
together and I think and I think they do
you know there are some some kind of I
think that you can really get at some
some core shifts but you know if you tug
on one of these you're gonna you're
going to see a lot a lot of a lot of
change right and maybe unexpected areas
but yeah so so the idea you know what
this is another one where it's a little
bit paradoxical right because there's
there's there's nothing that I can think
of that's that's more common in the West
at least then the desire to be
extraordinary or to be special and and I
think this kind of obsession gives us a
odd relationship to other people right
because if the ideal is the
extraordinary or the special then then
who are these people around us who are
not extraordinary or special like what
is their value and then also you know
what is your own value so until you
achieve this extraordinariness you are
less than which I think this is
unhelpful in a lot of ways we also we
also like one of the other kind of
boring things about the desire to be
extraordinary is that that that we all
basically want to be special in the same
ways like we want to be more famous we
want to be more rich
we want to be more powerful right
there's very few of us four or like I'm
going to be extra ordinarily loving or
kind or caring you know like there's not
a lot of that I mean there's a lot of
people saying that right but but they're
saying it loudly and in a way that makes
it look like maybe they want Fame more
than actual caring right so and actually
one of the things that they kind of
anchor to on on this one is it comes
from from Jack Kerouac and I I was read
this this must have been ten years ago
now is this brain pickings posted a
bunch of writing advice from from Jack
Kerouac and he and it was just three
words respect your experience and you
know so so Mr Emerson later put it this
way you know he said trust thyself every
heart vibrates to that iron string and
so the paradox here is that if we can
drop this need to be special and
extraordinary we then free ourselves to
be more creative productive happy and
authentic so if because because we don't
have our our sense of what is ordinary
right is our life as it is and the the
need to be extraordinary then let puts
this layer of disrespect on our life as
it is right so we come from this anxious
place of needing this very specific very
like we talked about boring vision of a
world of a new world for ourselves but
if we're able to take a step back we can
free ourselves from kind of that mimetic
you know like mimetic desire of of
needing what our neighbors have to
actually doing the things that are most
energizing and exciting and meaningful
for us and this you know I return to
that Emerson line my life is for itself
and
for a spectacle it's like we're not here
to to create a life that somebody can go
write a book about and make it a
best-seller right like that's not the
point of living I mean you know again
like I'm not moralizing maybe that's but
that sounds like a like an absolute
nightmare to me like the point is to
craft a life that is lived beautifully
and well and you know for me you as
generously and and hopefully if
hopefully just a good life right and and
you want that to be an internal
experience so so yeah and I think I
think if you can release even just
trying to you know release this desire
for specialness it can be it can be
really liberating that sounds or that
might be taken by some people as
accepting a life of mediocrity
mmm-hmm yeah and that's so that's the
this was when I was setting us around to
people you know that the article to put
that was a big place for pushback is you
know yeah we don't want a mediocre
mediocre life right and so the point
isn't at all that we shouldn't strive
right the first thing we talked about
was was struggle and the point isn't at
all to to be small the point is to be
more yourself and to Kevin Kelley
actually has this really great advice to
you know find you know find the thing
that only you can do and do that but
you're never going to do that if you're
trying for some very you know if you're
if you're if you're starting trying to
be extraordinary right at least I don't
think so I haven't seen the people who
end up doing the most interesting
fascinating unexpected things are those
who who find some
interest that they have in their life
and then follow that and follow that and
follow that and and amplify that and and
that's where I think some of the most
interesting art comes from some of the
most like touching you know speeches or
or writing right like someone who who
who sets out to write a book trying to
communicate as authentically as possible
their idea of you know of something is
it's going to be much more pleasant to
read and and paradoxically probably have
a higher chance of success because they
can actually speak to someone then
someone who starts out to write like a
magnum opus I'm gonna write my great
work right and people you can get away
with that like if you're already super
experienced in ridiculously skilled or
have some like genius intellect right
but like especially in starting starting
out I think you know if you start out
from a foundation of respect for your
life your worldviews you're going to
you're going to create something much
more stable and if you start from a
place of well my view doesn't matter
until I achieve X right like or I get X
followers or you know so I think and I
think the shortcut there is to respect
your own life
respect your own struggles and respect
doesn't mean give in - right like so so
there's somebody's respecting your
experience if you're you're struggling
with overeating or laziness whatever it
is it doesn't it doesn't mean it it
doesn't mean that you should just keep
doing that right like obviously you
don't that's that your deep desire is
not to continue on that path but to look
at it respect it actually reminds me
that Carl Rogers this psychologist has
this line he says the the curious
paradox is that when I accept myself as
I am then I can change
I think that's what this shift is about
right
if the extraordinary is what who we are
not
then embracing the ordinary and is is
you know embracing who we are now even
if we want to grow yeah there's a long
way of getting there but I think is that
I I love it I really like the idea of
wanting an extraordinary life being
disrespectful to the person that you are
I think it's I think that's very very
true as well you know any of the the
sort of type a people as well that are
listening you'll know what it's like you
can do the thing that you said that you
were going to do and still feel
dissatisfaction in having achieved it
because that's only the thing that you
did at your level of doing rather than
it being well like that person's
obviously doing it at that level I know
I did it my way or I did that work out I
run the marathon in four hours and ten
minutes but I leave Kip Jogi run it in
two hours you know so like who the [ __ ]
am I like it was all right but you never
actually allow yourself to pat yourself
on the back for your own accomplishments
because there's always this desire for
more it's the it's the inner soul
equivalent of a materialist wealth
mindset you know it's like this sort of
hedonic treadmill for self-worth almost
it's constraining like it narrows your
vision which you know like in in certain
types of athletics can be really helpful
but in a more kind of like open-world
game if you will it's way less helpful
because like we talked about earlier you
can get stuck very easily on the wrong
hill you can you can get you can you can
win the game and then realise you're
playing the wrong game full-time yeah
Mon so um we've gone through the the
four different layers I want to revisit
my favorite passage
from the blog and then I'm gonna get you
to give everyone who's listening some
tips and some advice on how to sustain
change we've read pilled them but what
you know what some of the next actions
that they can take as they move forward
also gonna give you an opportunity to
make any changes that you you've changed
you've altered your mindset on in the
last four years since then but this is
my favorite passage and this was kind of
the one I think that made me really fall
in love with the articles so my biggest
fear is to live a life I regret it's
easy to fall into the trap Proust is
talking about and spend life blindly
chasing something you never actually
wanted blindly following your desires
makes you a slave to your impulses slave
to the assumptions of those around you
the advertisements you're exposed to and
the confused chemical signals of your
body
our default is to spend our life as rats
blindly chasing the next dopamine hit
this isn't a setting easily adjusted but
it's worth shifting our aims and
becoming fully human
if we don't pause and ask ourselves what
we want to want we will spend our lives
focused on those unhealthy aims defined
for us by others and the worst parts of
ourselves we will pass these bad
assumptions about life on to our
children and loved ones we will
reinforce these boring desperate
defaults and everyone we encounter to
achieve freedom we must be able to think
for ourselves if we don't cut to the
core and program our wants our desires
then our best-case scenario is to be the
most successful rich or famous slave if
we never peer into our programming then
we may end up being the cleverest rat
but that's hardly worth celebrating
asking yourself what you want to want
can help you avoid wanting the wrong
things that's it man you nailed it with
that so good
thank you sir yeah that I I think that
that summary did yeah makes me want to
ask the question so good anyway so we
are moving on first things first what
have you changed your mind about on this
article since you did it you may maybe
nothing but have you changed your mind
on anything so you gave me yeah
opportunity to get to revisit this and
and there's nothing there's a there's a
lot of little things that change as a
writer of course but the only big shift
that I would make and and this is purely
a I think a phase of life situation is
that I would focus more on shifting into
things being nourishing or wholesome in
the long run for life rather than kind
of emphasizing this the struggle
throughout and so I think that would be
that would be like a big that would be
just a tonal shift because I think I
what what comes off and what I what I
think I you know and it depends how you
old you are right so like a 22 year old
is probably needs like the warrior
mindset right like you're fighting
you're you you you it feels good to be
pushing against something constantly
right but then you get a little bit
older maybe you have kid like things
things shift and so I think that yet the
tone and this is why I think
self-reliance is so important in in
asking questions like this right like
the whole point of this is to explore
your desires if you were to choose your
desires what would they be and and yeah
so so for me now the things that
resonate more are pushing more towards
nourishing wholesome kind of sustainable
shifts and also I'd also add I think I
think there's a lot of value to
accepting current desires like we just
talked about in the
you know the the ordinary and and doing
more subtle work and uncovering our
desires so so we talked about the
accepting quite a bit it was you know
the Carl Rogers line the curious paradox
is that when I accept myself as I am
then I can change so so although we're
talking about shifting very deep parts
of ourselves we have to simultaneously
acknowledge and accept those things and
then also I think I find shadow work
really really interesting and that's
basically you know for our purposes here
finding desires that aren't quite
obvious and so so Robert Bly offers a
really practical example of this in his
book a little book of the human shadow
he suggests that we think about someone
that you really hate you can do this
right now like I think about someone you
you really dislike rubs you the wrong
way or it just drives you insane
right and you you probably think about
as person I am NOT like that and my
whole purpose in existing is to be not
like that right so and then you know
take a step further think about the
traits that make you hate them the most
the ones that get under your skin the
most and if we're being honest if we do
this with a little bit of humility we
can probably find pieces in our self
desires that we have that we really
don't like right so we can find the
things that we hate most and others tend
to be the kind of unseen or rejected
pieces of our self and I think so I
think that's what that's really
interesting practice another source for
for shadow shadow work shadow hunting is
Dave Chapman who's the author of the
site meaning this but he has a he has
another cycle Buddhism for vampires and
so so another suggestion for finding
these kind of hidden desires is to pay
attention to kind of weaker once or
desires that you would normally not act
at all that kind of her just like a
passing you know passing wind and grab
hold of them and you know he calls these
Bella tease Emerson might call them a
whim and you know like so so if we're
trying to discover what we really want
out of life or you know what what do you
you know what do you really want what do
you want to learn you know even if
you're just looking to learn about
yourself a bit more you know Mr Emerson
said about this kind of shadow hunting
that you know he says he hopes that this
is better than a whim at last
but we cannot spend the day in
explanation so I think our our talkative
minds will often reject our actual once
and then because we've rejected our true
natural and maybe more wholesome desires
that just happen we're repressing for
for one reason or another maybe it's
societal norms or it's inconvenient or
whatever those are then hidden and
replaced by less nourishing less
wholesome desires so I think I think you
know this isn't someone we talk about a
lot but like actually finding your true
desires it would have been worth
exploring well let's do it we've still
got time on before we move on to that
actually I want to I want to say about
that the the lowest lower level of
stimulus thing that I mentioned that
allowed me to appreciate the trees on my
street or they hi yeah
may that made you focus on your leaf for
15 minutes I think that ties in it's the
the ordinary versus extraordinary thing
and by thinking that life should be
grander than it is we almost feel a
little bit embarrassed or shameful of
some of the wants that we have so for
instance I hid my intellectual curiosity
for probably the best part of a decade
from when I got to uni and became a club
promoter and was that big dick on campus
all this stuff until pretty much until
just after loved Island when I got
delivered that fatal dose of contrast
between me and the guys who were the
persona I was trying to play but I was I
was like a Shane oh yeah it kind of
ashamed of it just a little bit like I
didn't think that that was the vision of
what a young man was supposed to be I
was around a very alpha male type a
mentality and I just meant that I didn't
allow myself to indulge in that I didn't
want to admit the fact that I watched I
had a desire to watch space
documentaries on a night time I was
embarrassed about my empathy I thought
that it was a shut a sign of weakness
the fact that I genuinely feel
discomfort when I see someone else
suffer and I can't get over that I was
like ah that's not what a courageous
alpha male does that's not what a man's
supposed to do they're supposed to be
able to deal with things you know like
so all of these different bits and
pieces I had covered over with mimetic
or kind of unwanted once I would want to
be seen as a powerful man that want to
be seen as a capable businessman the
what to want to be seen as someone who a
man who is attractive to women because
of the stereotypical characteristics
that he thinks women find attractive you
know roll o'clock forward as much as you
want and it's only upon doing
introspective work to find out what my
truth was that I've actually been able
to embrace now that not only as
tongue-in-cheek desires but as proud
parts of me like the fact that I have
crushing crippling empathy is sometimes
sometimes inconvenient but I'm proud of
it
you know like why shouldn't I be proud
about the fact that I desperately care
or that sometimes when I see a dog that
looks really happy I want to cry like
why should I feel upset about that why
should I feel embarrassed about that why
should I feel embarrassed about the fact
that I've got this intellectual
curiosity because if I hadn't allowed
that to reman effect itself
I'd be 2 and 1/2 million downloads less
without a podcast or a project that I
care about but the fact that I did do
that has permitted me to do this thing
and meet all these cool people and
connect with a an audience that loves
the project and then find random
strangers on the other side of the
planet like yourself get a piece of work
that I think is fantastic and then use
my show as a delivery system to then try
and distribute that understanding and
learning to make thousands and thousands
of other people's lives better you know
like if that's not an argument for
trying to deprogram the ones that you
haven't worked out if you wanted to want
like I don't know what it is
yeah that's that's incredible
transformation what do you what was the
the impetus or what did those first
steps look like were they big were they
small you know like what was it was it
you know letting yourself put on that
space document or like what were
something do you remember some of the
zone early yeah good good question again
with that so I think um I think that
starting to see it was it was a good
time for it to happen because it was the
advent of the Jordan Peterson era oh
yeah it was a time when sort of 2017
just as he was coming to the fore and
just as Rogan was really really starting
to pick up speed and you could learn
from someone like ben shapiro or sam
Harris or Brier Eric Weinstein or John
Peterson whoever it might be there was
like tons of mindful content floating
around and you were just able to swim in
it man so that was that was a big part
for me like learning to tell the truth
was the the single biggest change that I
made and hopefully today we have
encouraged people that there is huge
huge value in understanding what their
own truth is so you'd mentioned you
mentioned something that you thought
that we could revisit and then I also
want to also want to look at some of the
tactics that people can use to reinforce
wanting the right things of how we can
make ourselves want the right things so
I was actually talking the examples of
the shadow work so the you know
recognizing that the people who you hate
the most likely are useful mirrors to
find desires in yourself that you've
repressed and the exercise of kind of
paying attention as closely as you
possibly can to whims or kind of the
little quiet desires that you you you
normally would just ignore and kind of
look into and give those a chance
those are the two kind strategies that I
would forgot I need you forgot man I've
got another one for you real real small
one um anyone who's thinking oh this all
sounds well and good Chris like it's
cool that you've found a passion but I
don't know what mine is think back to
what you did between the age of 8 and 14
for fun think about some of the stuff
that you did there does this example the
world's best color picker it's a lady
and she got asked on this interview like
so she makes these amazing designs for
different clothing companies of
different interior design companies and
stuff like that with selecting just the
quite the right shade of of pastel pink
to go with this shade of pastel blue and
blah blah blah and somebody asked her an
interview so what are your
qualifications why are you so good at
this so why I you know I've done a lot
of continuous pressure to professional
development listen the other but really
it all stems from when I was 9 and for
Christmas I got the biggest box of
Crayola from my mom and dad that I could
get and and just ever since then you
know I've just loved matching colors
I've loved doing that and I think back
to my childhood between the age of 8 and
14 and what was i spending a lot of time
doing I'm an only child so I was
listening to audiobooks that audio tapes
like His Dark Materials by Philip
Pullman like 40 tapes 40 double-sided
tape back-to-back across three tomes
like 6070 hours and what is the 2020
audio book if it's not a podcast so
that's a good that's a good way I think
to kind of look at some of the things
that used to bring you joy especially if
you've spent a long time perhaps mapping
over that with societal norms and path
of least resistance and all that stuff
think back to what you did as a kid
think back to the stuff that you enjoyed
yeah this that's perfect I think that's
an awesome example it's super quiet love
think of you running around with like
tapes in it it was really cool okay so
how do we make ourselves want the right
things what some of the tactics people
can use to reinforce wanting the right
things so the article has a ton I don't
want to use up our audio here to go
through too many of the little ones but
I think you know the core ones are your
community so paying really you know do
the people and communities you spend
time in want to want the same things
that you want to want so you know and
this is you know CrossFit oh it is like
obviously incredible place for someone
who wants to desire to work out you know
there's there's few better places to go
if you want to you really want to work
out I think of like worship communities
for people who want to get you know grow
spiritually in some way even you know
some and this is all your various sizes
and play different roles and and effect
different desires so like I've been
experimenting a lot with book clubs just
as ways of even with just me and one
other person where we're reading a book
together and then talking about you know
it's like picking someone who you want
to want like you know and and finding
ways of just spending more time in their
presence right your marriage right like
you're your partner is is obviously a
huge huge I mean I think Ryan holiday
said like that's the best life hack ever
I think that's letting a good partner
yeah like if you can get a great partner
whose desires are maybe even a little
bit ahead of yours on you know on
certain spectrums of these you know
desires that we were talking about that
that can do a lot of work for you you
know then the the company that you work
for what's a culture like what is what
kind of design
do they do they add so anytime there's
people involved I think that's like
that's probably the highest leverage
area where we can where we can start
shifting our desires I think regular
reflection especially journaling where
there's a record right so you can see a
if you if you if you are desiring or
failing to kind of push yourself in a
certain direction like you see that over
time right and it's painfully obvious
how little attention or how frequently
you're struggling with a certain desire
and I think those reminders go a long
way
internal scorecards are popularized by
Warren Buffett who basically talks about
how he has an internal scorecard for
investing and that internal versus
external so an external scorecard is you
know what are the returns on the fund
versus internal and I executing on my
strategy in a way that I that I believe
is good right and and being able to
separate out you know this is just goes
back to the fame versus doing thing
right you if you have an internal
scorecard that is measuring what you're
actually doing and taking action on
that's going to help a lot and pushing
you through kind of these asymmetric
activities where you have to do a ton of
a ton of hard work that may or not may
or may not pay off especially in the
short run and and and if you're just
using an external scorecard like what's
my follower count how much money am I
making it's going to it's going to
de-energize you very quickly so I think
those three are pretty pretty powerful
especially again the communities I think
everything follows from that honestly
well you re jigging the mimetic
predisposition that we have to your
advantage right yes yes such a such a
cliche you are the average of the five
people that you spend the most time with
but you got to think now like there will
be some people in lockdown some people
listening right now
perhaps for whom I am one of the people
that they've spent the most time with
during lockdown
you know like they've listened to this
podcast more than they've seen the fifth
or the the bottom fifth person in their
life that make sense you know like some
podcasts right they have total control
if someone they're not finding what they
need in there it like in the physical
area around them it's so podcast is such
a low-friction way of like spending time
with different types of feeling
connected you know yeah yeah I think
you're totally right with that like um
getting yourself a squad of people who
are like the person that you want to be
like and obviously what that the
implication of that is that you need to
work out what you want to want or else
you're just going to think oh well that
guy over there he's got he's the one
with the Ferrari or he's like oh hang on
a second
I listen to that podcast with Kyle and
Chris and they said frugal ha let me
that means I probably need to go back to
a little bit more work and then maybe
you're fully actualized me like actually
yeah I do want a Ferrari cuz it shit-hot
cool if that's you speaking your truth
forward yeah I think that's great the
internal scorecard thing as well man
like that is the marker of someone who
is so resilient like everyone will have
that friend who just seems not
unflappable but just like they're always
on their own path you know like stuffing
all right stuff will go wrong but
they've just got this higher higher
purpose this kind of road that they're
walking they don't really ever seem to
get kind of flustered if they do have
setbacks they overcome them I got a
buddy suni Webster who's been on the
show twice a lot of people listening all
know who he is excellent peon Olympic
weightlifter and man that guy just keeps
on coming up against big setbacks in one
form or another and he just steamrolls
them he absolutely fortin's them which
is easy when you've got like 28 inch
legs but he
completely annihilate s' whatever
happens to him he's a oh okay cool
that's a thing but doesn't matter I'm
just doing my thing I'm on my path
completing my journey and he doesn't
give a [ __ ] man
it's so inspiring I love being around
him I adore being around him that's
awesome I I was always thinking of that
as somebody is so interested in their
own game that they don't have time to be
worried about their score on a game that
they're not playing right like they're
they're so fascinated and you know into
their own game and I think that's that's
the goal bro that is eight when you are
so interested in your own game you don't
care about the score on a game you're
not playing [ __ ] yes I love it
look man any parting remarks any parting
thoughts any anything that you'd want to
leave the listeners with we've sort of
thrown a lot at them obviously the blog
post will be linked below so people can
go and read it in full but yeah anything
you want to leave them with yeah I just
hope you you you sincerely ask yourself
what do you want to want especially in
hard times especially when you're being
forced to reconsider values anyway it's
a perfect opportunity to say is that
what I really wanted anyway is it
possible that this is actually an
opportunity to to go after what I truly
want and yeah yeah so I you know ask
that question over and over and over and
over again and and I promise it it can
be helpful on how amazing look where can
people find you online
AUM have you got any plans 2020
considering writing any more stuff as
well
yeah I need to I need to it's been a
yeah I'm on I'm on Twitter collection
but I actually I have I have a draft of
something then I've been noodling on you
know I have to run by you dude you go to
get it out there man if it's if it's
even at a hundredth of what what do you
want to want is then you got to get out
there look I'm really glad to everybody
that's made it through this podcast I
know there's a lot to take in I know
there's a lot of kind of different
concepts and it can sound a little bit
sort of uh no like erudite and esoteric
sometimes while we're talking about
these real fluffy concepts but I
wouldn't have gone out of my way to try
and deliver this message if I didn't
think it was something that really can
move the needle in your life like this
is we are talking about the fundamental
underpinnings of why you are here and
then on top of that what the
implications are of that relate to how
you're going to operate within the world
and the things that you do very much so
can constitute the legacy of what
happens when you're gone you know so you
should very very seriously consider
everything that we've gone through today
you should totally go and read what you
want to want on Kyle's blog which will
be linked in these show notes below and
if you've got any questions if you want
some clarification about bits and piece
or if you just got some ideas at Chris
will X or at Kyle ashen which will also
be linked in the show notes below on
Twitter or wherever it is that you
follow us Kyle man thank you so much and
thank you for your work as well you know
this is a this really is a [ __ ]
magnum opus of a blog post so you know
congratulations from someone who's five
years late on saying it but but really
appreciate your work thanks so much man
this has been awesome
[Music]
you